Arts relationships hard enough as they
are and once you add children into the
equation and and this is just children
in general not we we don't have a
specific number it could be one two
three four five or more it just makes it
the relationship more complicated not
only do you have to have a relationship
with the woman you need a relationship
with each individual child too if she
lets you and you if you are a man
who would consider getting into a
relationship like that maybe you don't
know what these kids are like how you
would be as a father because you're
picking up where either nobody left off
or where someone else left off